here's a good one the United States has
331 million people in it and Donald
Trump claims that his decisions on
coronavirus have saved possibly billions
of people who otherwise would have died
it makes as much sense to me as it makes
to you I think let's take a look at the
video 60,000 or so that's a lot of
people but that's a hundred thousand was
the minimum we thought that we could get
to and we will be lower than that number
anywhere from a hundred to two hundred
and twenty thousand people but I really
believe it could have been billions of
people had we not done what we did we
made a lot of good decisions but one of
those things go ahead it could have been
billions of people had we not done what
we did
billions of people only 331 million live
in the United States if Trump is
claiming that shutting down flights from
China in early February saved billions
of people I just don't understand the
mathematics of it but let's pretend for
a second to take it seriously
world population believed to be just shy
of seven point eight billion right now
seven point eight billion people on
planet Earth in the completely
unreasonable and cartoonish worst case
we're not a single country did anything
nobody did suppression nobody did
mitigation and coronavirus spread
globally worst case about 7 billion
people get it you you would never have
everyone get infected that's not how
viruses work but imagine it that of the
seven point eight billion people on
earth seven billion get infected maybe
forty million people would die that'd be
about point six percent if you went
crazy and you say let's double that
eighty million people would die again
these are completely irrelevant numbers
because it assumes no country does
anything at all even if you do that it
is ridiculous for Trump to be talking
about saving billions of people and
Trump says that merely stopping flights
from China could have saved a billion or
billions of people how do you save
billions when your country has
131 million people in it I had this
hilarious idea which obviously is not
what Trump meant but this is the type of
stuff I think about based on so at some
point the Sun is going to grow and
engulf planet Earth and planet Earth
will no longer be habitable for the homo
sapiens
maybe we've moved on to some other solar
system we don't know but okay forget
about that for a second imagine that you
save fifty thousand people today and you
calculate how many progeny are they
likely to have how many kids how many
offspring will those fifty thousand
people have and then how many offspring
will those kids have and then how many
not right and you go until the Sun
engulfs the earth is it possible in that
way Trump's actions compared to doing
nothing may have saved billions of
people I wonder what the number would
actually be and again it doesn't matter
because what Trump's saying makes no
sense but that's a little a little bit
of a peek behind the curtain as to where
my mind goes when I read this type of
stuff of course Donald Trump is not
capable of that type of thought it's not
what he meant
but it crossed my mind Trump now saying
billions billions are the numbers of
people saved by his actions on
coronavirus you can't make this stuff up
folks if you ever feel like you just
don't have enough time to read all the
books you want to read you have to check
out one of my favorite apps called
blinka splink a-- stakes thousands of
popular nonfiction books and distills
each one down into an e-book or audio
book that you can get through in just 15
minutes where you're getting all the key
takeaways from the book just imagine how
you'll be able to expand your horizons
and knowledge by being able to soak up
all of the important insights from 10
different books in an afternoon
obviously it's perfect for exposing
yourself to a new book you otherwise
wouldn't have time for or you can use it
to revisit a book you've already read or
use it to preview a book before you buy
the full version and read it I recently
read a brief history of time of course
by the great Stephen Hawking this is a
book that I have been aware of for so
long and other things got in the way
and it was fantastic to check it out on
blinka stinkiest has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about 8 bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
is comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video